les aurores boréales sont parmi les
spectacles céleste des plus majestueux
elle s'accompagne parfois d'un autre
phénomène à conférer plus mystérieux un
long ruban violet et blanc observé par
les amateurs d'aurores depuis des années
ce phénomène nommé steve est maintenant
scrutées par les scientifiques
[Musique]
voici steve un long ruban violet et
blanc qui s'invite parfois au bal
nocturne des aurores un phénomène
atmosphérique mystérieux que les
amateurs observe depuis des années mais
les scientifiques eux le découvre à
peine et tente maintenant de l'expliquer
[Musique]
l'histoire commence en 2016
né aux loges un photographe passionné
d'aurores boréales montra des
astrophysiciens de l'université de
calgary
l'image d'un arc de cercle viol est
observé dans le ciel du sud de la
province
il croit qu'il s'agit d'une autre sorte
d'aurore plus rares un arc de protons
impossible répondent les chercheurs les
arcs de protons sont invisibles à l'oeil
nu
s'agirait-il alors d'un nouveau type
d'aurores boréales
pour le savoir il faut d'abord rappeler
ce qu'est une aurore
ce phénomène débute à la surface du
soleil notre étoile aimé du plasma un
gaz formé de particules électrisé ce
vent solaire se dirige vers la terre et
interfère avec les lignes du champ
magnétique terrestre qui change de forme
les lignes s'étirent puis se brise
vision et des électrons sont alors
précipités vers la terre il entre en
collision avec les gaz de la haute
atmosphère et libèrent leur énergie sous
forme de lumière le ciel s'embrase alors
au pôle des protons émis par le soleil
peuvent aussi provoquer des aurores mais
celles ci sont invisibles à l'oeil nu
[Musique]
alors quel est le lien entre
l'énigmatique ruban et ces phénomènes
en attendant d'avoir la réponse les
chasseur d'aurores réunis sur internet
l'ont baptisé steve une référence à un
film d'animation où des animaux sauvages
découvre le monde des humains sous la
forme d'une paix puisque six est vrai
moins peur si je savais comment ça
s'appelle
on n'a qu'à l'appeler sriw thibault
comme lorrain il n'y a qu'un moyen de
comprendre ce que c'est que cette chose
est de savoir de quoi il s'agit
observation steve fait une vingtaine de
kilomètres de large
ils s'accompagnent parfois de très vert
qui rappelle une clôture
il s'allonge sur plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres
à des latitudes plus près de l'équateur
que celle où on voit habituellement les
aurores ses apparitions sont de courte
durée ils se produisent peu temps après
le début de rohr particulièrement
intense
[Musique]
pour en savoir plus des chercheurs
canadiens et américains se sont basés
sur des images de steve prise en 2016
par un adepte d'aurore de la
saskatchewan
celle ci leur ont permis de retrouver le
phénomène parmi les données fournies par
des caméras au sol et des satellites à
deux reprises ils ont pu analyser le
phénomène en détail
quand des satellites ont croisé steve
[Musique]
leurs conclusions steve n'est pas une
aurore lésions qui le constituent se
déplace à l'horizontale et non sous
forme de précipitation vers la terre
comme dans une aurore ce flux d'ions et
hors du commun ils se déplacent d'est en
ouest à plus de 6 kilomètres à la
seconde et atteint des températures de
près de 5800 degrés celsius des
températures semblables à celles qu'on
retrouve à la surface du soleil
les chercheurs concluent que steve
pourrait être une version plus intense
et exceptionnellement visible d'un
phénomène déjà connue appelée dérive
ionique sub aurorale associés aux
aurores il se forme dans la haute
atmosphère sans qu'on comprenne encore
commun
en attendant ces découvertes ont permis
à steve de conserver son nom devenu en
anglais un acronyme liées à ses
propriétés exceptionnelles qu'on
pourrait traduire par augmentation de
vitesse de fortes émissions thermiques
en plus de son étonnant ballet nocturne
steve révèle un autre phénomène
important
la collaboration parfois lumineuse entre
amateurs et scientifique
[Musique]
on